month and a Day Las Vegas will get a
taste of what formula one is all about
F1 bringing its grand three kickoff
party to Las Vegas sports director Chris
Matthews has more details for this
afternoon Chris all right thank you very
much guys yes some Motorsports fans may
remember when NASCAR held its drivers
were roping down the strip there were
Las Vegas the Grand Prix party November
5th will be similar to that only this
time you'll see those drivers in the 15
million dollar machines put on a
demonstration on this trip like we've
never seen before Clark County
Commission approving the closure of the
Las Vegas Strip from 4 30 until 7 P.M on
November 5th full closure from Harrah's
to Paris for an F1 demonstration where
drivers from Red Bull and Mercedes will
show what fans these F1 cars are all
about now the drivers will start at
Caesar's Palace and roll down south on
this trip to Paris make a turn right
there and return The Fan Fest will run
from 11 A.M to 11 p.m and they're
already promoting the event take a
listen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right during the day fans can
participate in a pit stop challenge
Formula One will have exhibits and of
course you'll be able to buy merchandise
and at night there will be a drone show
over Caesar's Palace all this happening
on November 5th workers still uh have to
you know that the close process of some
of the strip there on November 3rd
that's when they'll start and then by
the sixth every everything should be
back up in normal they're also working
on ways to get those shift employees
affected by the kickoff party to and
from work exciting stuff there Christian